what is happening reason ation it is
Greg Aoi yeah so we saw the movie atomic
balloon atomic blonde this movie is way
better than John wick and is exactly
what you wanted and showing wick it's
already better than Deadpool - it's
already better than Deadpool - I'm
telling you guys man
best movie or the I want to know okay I
realize we never actually you know give
what the plot is about like every other
movie review on YouTube you're ready for
it it's like in my future him Morgan
shows basic hoarded all the water that
this 1980s Berlin Wall is up its up but
it hasn't come down just yet takes place
just a few days before this happens this
list you know those spy movies were the
list of everyone all sorta high all the
spies you know you've seen plenty of
movies do this blot in order and then
it's been stolen and then someone's
trying to sell it or something get that
list word winds up in the wrong hand
they send in Lorraine Brockton played by
Charlize Theron's to go and retrieve the
list and she has to team up with James
MacGuffin doubt you know who has the
list and of course there's deception
along the way there's bigger plot
intrigues or double crosses of a problem
across oh man oh man it crumb make it
round more exciting in the movie
actually John what's our up with some
positive that's alright there are some
positives there are not this definite
positives
Charlize Theron a badass if you saw the
trailer for this movie and you were like
whoa Charlize you look sexy you look
badass you look like you drink like this
movie and like you trained she does all
that man she is killer in this rule this
is the weird movie where everything you
thought you were going to get from the
trailer is there but the movie is not
exactly what you thought it was going to
be yeah yeah and Charlize Theron she
does a really good job in the
physicality and the badassness of this
personally I would have liked her
character to be a little more
interesting in terms of the writing
Department but for what they gave
Charlize Theron to do she definitely is
the star of this whole movie yeah the
main reason to watch this she is the
nucleus of this entire area and and she
is the atomic bomb Perseus and there are
a number of moments in which she lives
up to that title out you know totally
and you could tell she really did put in
the physical training and ever for this
man like we're just grading this movie
on Charlize Theron well now God would be
you know really high up on on whatever
our rating scale is James McAvoy he's
really good in the movie out of all the
characters that get a chance to do some
different things and shine and really
have fun with their roles
it's definitely James McAvoy yeah so he
has one of those roles where you're like
he's hopped back and forth between can
we trust this guy and is he you know is
he out of his mind or is he actually a
pretty calm and collected and you know
just just putting up a good front you
know and there's a lot of that with
these characters across or there's a lot
of deception and who's on his I am who's
crazy double agent at least the main
cast seems like they get to demonstrate
different signs of debtor's originality
which is cool to watch like the
performances are some of the best parts
of this movie and McAvoy is definitely
one of the top oh absolutely sofia
boutella
Bhutto block you know that actress who's
really hot who never really quite get
the chance it's really shine in the
world she's kind of kept it yeah I I
wish somebody would let her like I don't
know star in something or every time
I've seen her in a movie I feel like
I've been like yeah I like you a lot I
wish you had more to do she's really
good in the film though she is not
exactly a badass character like the
trailer might lead you to think she is
she's one of the more vulnerable
characters she is a breath of fresh air
in terms of the kinds of characters you
get and the way they emotes yeah
definitely especially for like the spy
world cuz sure character is like a fresh
spot and you know they do have that you
know lesbian scene which is awesome it's
like an action lesbian pretty good like
almost like a fight scene in The Wiz
actions like before I'm really into this
they're also like you know trading yeah
I don't know what you've got they really
commit to it and I will say that this
film the first half is not all that
interesting it really isn't like it
starts off in a way where you think it's
so it's going to pick up steam it's
going to put and then it just doesn't
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
like thinking you're about to shift and
um I out here and then it you develop it
and a lot of oh we're about to get a
really cool action scene and then the
action scene takes place you're like
passable yeah not a great day yeah yeah
and and you know the thing is like so
many of these scenes have good things in
them but the way that they they
orchestrate the build-up it's like right
away you kind of adjusted the idea that
you're doing not crazy-ass action movie
not now while you're doing a spy movie
the thing is the first half is really
not that interesting it's actually
because the stakes are not really felt
it's just a lot of plot heavy
information yeah chasing is slow it
doesn't feel as important in the movie
seems to yeah what movie think is my
cooler than was actually oh you could
tell like the filmmakers thought this is
more interesting to then than the
audience will find it yeah it's like a
compelling Nastase feels like they're
not bad like it's an alright plot it
lived in spy movie but at the same time
you're like this isn't as compelling as
I want it to be and I'm not quite sure
why some of the time whereas I decided
bring all this up was because I felt
like the movie didn't start shifting
gears into actual interesting territory
until Sophia boot Ellis character was
firmly established as to who she is yeah
when she really shows up the apps like
the mid point about how yeah about half
way I like the second half of this movie
probably better I enjoyed it a lot more
in the first because that's when
personal stakes start to feel lived in
so that's what yeah that's one actual
like intensity what it doesn't like
totally shift into this one was intense
and gripping it starts to fluctuate in
that arena a lot more often right around
the time her character is firmly
introduced when she meets with Charlize
Theron is character more mystery starts
to pop up I think stopped going quite
according to plan and that
when things start to shift around
exactly exactly so she's great in this
film the action scenes for the most part
are just alright most of them are just
they're good they look cooler in the
trailer like they're all good yeah but
they're not exactly the most exciting
thing although and I'm sure you've heard
plenty of other people talk about this
the big stairwell fight that they
advertised in the trailer they shown at
comic-con I know that they showed a
specific portion of that at comic-con
but it's even longer than what they
showed at comic-con that is fantastic
that is a stellar that is amazing that
sequence blew me away glowing continued
as a matter of that kept blowing you but
having to build up to that fight made
the rest of the movie seem a little more
worth it I just wish the journey along
the way was more interesting so the
build-up was even more rewarding by the
time we got to that bike is that fight
was fantastic it's primarily in one shot
it's one of those spices all in one take
you know like when she's an effing the
heck of the people what a lot of sensory
that's always been that a guy after like
getting bruised up there getting
exhausted and there's blood gushing and
stuff you should said a lot like how are
they doing the making where the makeup
come and like some of the blood splatter
like on the walls you can tell you see
you have the time you're like they're
bleeding yeah every bases are getting
more messed up and you're just panning
around like it's one of those like one
long shot I was like a daredevil yeah
you know it was an incredible sequence
that takes place even at further past
the hallway fighting that whole finale
is pedant is much better than the
entirety of event but yeah you kind of
wish that kind of what about the other
stuff a movie has been as grinning and
as cool and as you know and really
delivered like that scene is the one one
of the parts of this movie that delivers
on the promise that we all got excited
yeah exactly and it's worth watching for
that one fight oh it is I mean you could
you could just like rent the movie and
go to that buy it if you want but you
might enjoy this more on video I think
you would yeah I think you would be
especially if you're like going in fully
aware this is one of the dudes did John
wick I thought okay this is going back
more to the John wick one territory
whereas there's no action in the
beginning and then once we get to an
action freaking sweep and it doesn't
ever hit that mark until you're in the
finale of the movie but you're like
there is what everybody for this matter
but yeah and even so that there's not
quite as much catharsis in the abyss as
John wick so that's another kind of
thing that it is missing for this kind
of movie especially about you know spies
and double-crossing and and for as much
bone-crunching action as they put in
that trailer you expected a little more
catharsis the cinematography is great
the lighting of library amazing editing
for the most part is pretty yeah there
are a couple fights that I actually
thought could have been shot and cut
better and you know a lot of people I
feel are comparing this to the music
choice to Suicide Squad I wouldn't put
it on that level Suicide Squad is a
random playlist okay that is that is
David Ayer putting his playlist on
random this movie at least had a
consistency with 80s pop music yeah I
wasn't like how solarizing son let us
play some Eminem here yeah I was like it
was cool music yeah but in a context and
it all kind of flowed with the theme or
yeah inside squad just feels like check
out all these cool songs yeah this
movie's music choices aren't edited or
composed as well as something like baby
driver but I didn't find it to be
problematic it was a little indulgent I
don't know why so many people are
complaining about it yeah and there were
actually honestly there are a couple
editing choices with the music that
actually worked really well
totally I wouldn't call it necessarily
like a bad or terrible film I just think
it's more disappointing than anything
else yeah what it lacks is excitement
it's kind of tedious at times the plot
is surprisingly confusing and not that
interesting and that's a problem for me
what I'm like not only is this not that
interesting it's also kind of confusing
inside yeah and really the finale it
gets like over convoluted would twist
yeah get to that place where you're like
trying to keep up cuz you want to but
you're also like I don't why I feel like
really care anymore yeah you kind of
almost become not annoyed but it's in
that family of feelings yeah what is
wait hold on what and actually like the
characters are very much two-dimensional
I felt like the actors provided a lot
more than what the
writing provides this is another one of
those movies where like on one hand I
get not getting to know them super well
because the you know the point is
they're all spies and we don't know who
anybody is but at the same time yet it's
like there's something missing from
these characters that makes them just
less than gripping but they always have
moments for personal touches the big
part of the setup is Charlize Theron
like big motivation at least with the
film's hinting at is that this person
who got killed who had the list taken
away from them as someone she formerly
had an affair with or some type of
sexual romantic relationship with then
it seems like a little bit like this is
a big revenge factor for yeah it's kind
of just forget about it forget all about
never brought up again yeah under
Cheston easy I feel like I just kept
doing that every time it had a chance to
be more personal and have something more
emotionally at stake instead of
government plot stuff that's just what
would have made it better I mean I feel
like the pacing tries to be cool and
slow-moving but really it just makes the
movie feel slow and film thinks it's
cooler than what it is like that sort of
great trailer yeah you kind of issue
some of the new wavier elements where
you're watching people in cars or
they're you know sitting in pouring
drinks and then yeah doing stuff like
lot of smoking cigarettes yeah yeah yeah
yeah and those things aren't aren't bad
but they do start to rack up to a point
where you're like yeah these seem just
like stylistic flourishes yeah aren't
being paid off by much underneath it's
just void of emotional substance that's
basically it cyborgs we never we hardly
touch on this but the costume designs
the wardrobes in the Alvia are off the
chain like they're their greatness and
the sound designs really good too
because there are times where I was
wondering there's like certain scenes I
was thinking if there wasn't sound
effects but I find this as cringe-worthy
yeah so that's a sound I make you cringe
it area there definitely a couple is
overall the performances are really good
Charlize Theron as the atomic blonde
takes a lot of ass there's a great
finale action sequence in there that
lasts a good amount of time that makes
it really worth it and I know people in
the audience were very much invested in
that fight even they were kind of zoning
out and for that it's thinly written the
characters are not developed that well
it's kind of it's not that exciting
there's a plot movie it's not a
character yeah and the plot funny of
that
saying it's because it's like very
familiar and not that fresh we don't
really have a very specific rating
system we stick to but Wendy Lee asked
that and give it a score out of 10 and I
said five and John and I we talked up
for me at the same score six point five
out of ten yeah yeah I would go with a
with like a solid six and a half maybe
if I'm thinking about the stuff I love
maybe like a light seven yeah I feel
general goodwill towards you know it's
all right
yeah but I don't think it's as cool or
exciting or smart as it thinks it is
it's kind of it's just not a hundred
percent well guys that's our review of
atomic blonde subscribe to the rail
rejects you like that notification melt
that shot Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and you can check out our
patreon do it do it to it you'd like it
I guarantee it you're going to like the
way you look when you pledge